ou si c'est pas fait dans dans la
violence depuis le début ce n'est pas la
violence la fin ce n'est pas une
tentation du tout 2 le chanteur aux
communes apprentis chanteurs c'est taf
est basé sur une envie de d'explorer le
domaine des sons vie
[Musique]
non
je dirais que c'est du son c'est pas du
champ ne prétend pas chanter je sais pas
chanter j'ai pas là moi juste comme un
chanteur l'eau locaux là c'est donc une
espèce de besoin d explorer des domaines
émotionnel
le son reproduit en heure en moyenne
espèrent quelque chose qui m'a toujours
tellement frappé tellement forte
vraiment j'ai tout d'un coup enfin je
pense qu'on tient beaucoup d'aujourd'hui
et celui des fois d'entendre un show
soit absolument rené
[Musique]
comme la musique en france
et on se sent un peu comme un lieu long
laissons la vibration des sons produits
une espèce de même chose épidermique
comme ça tient très curieuse c'est un
acteur intelligent d'une sensibilité
extraordinaire et d'une très grande
curiosité et qu'il n'a pas cessé depuis
le début de sa carrière de développer
sans cesse ses moyens je me rends compte
que c'est pas des noms je me reprocher
l'importance d'un succès ce qui passe
entre les mots derrière l'humour c'est
très curieux une expérience mais ça
confirme à flot ce coup dur recherche du
scoop sans choses agréables je m'attends
à gloucester s'est élevé rejet assez
pour les vergers
oui au printemps surtout surtout au
printemps dans un hôtel bien sûr puis
les branches alourdit les schistes sur
la pomme c'est la santé
j'avais une pièce qui était végétarienne
à elle mangeait des beignets de
noisettes amandes une fois j'ai essayé
d'abandonner la viande on peut pas en
être prises
et puis et puis beaucoup dans ma vie
j'ai expérimenté une espèce veulent pas
de 20h mais enfin de l'intensité du
silence et du ski cependant silence et
j'ai souvent remarqué que l'on a un
souci cette nuit dans science une
beaucoup plus fort que ce tissu
discernement
deviens ne peut pas démarrer
allez mai
[Musique]